(upbeat music)
- If this were an
actress, who would it be?
Let's not go there.
- Yeah, there's no such
thing as an ugly person.
- For like the color, I like them spotty,
and for like it not
being so spotty like that
it's actually pretty good.
- I think it's too firm.
I like a nice soft banana.
- He threw it down in disgust,
declaring that it was not a good banana.
- You bite through it and you can
kind of feel your teeth breaking through
certain parts that are
really tough on the inside.
I don't like that.
- Smooth as fuck.
- This, I will tell you what,
this is not organic.
- No this is organic.
- No, it's not organic.
- Let's do a size test.
- Yeah, look how fat
and short this one is.
For sure organic.
This one, not organic.
- This one's clearly the organic banana.
- Organic.
- [Woman] Yep.
- This one's organic.
Come on.
- [Voiceover] You guys are both wrong!
- No!
- [Right] Look at you.
- Noooo!
I just am only picking things
based off of the opposite
of what you picked.
- Crushing it.
- I've already got
blackberry juice all over me.
- This is gonna ruin my Monday.
- It's gonna be so good, though.
Let's do it.
- Mmm.
- Oh my God!
- [Left] Wow! Wow!
- Wow!
- [Woman] There it is!
- That's one of the best
blackberries I ever had.
- Tastes like a cheap wine.
- We have a uniform blackness.
- Smaller.
- These are not as good, right?
- I found a bug in this one.
This one's organic.
- Now here's the problem:
These are much better;
promise you they're not organic.
- I think these are organic.
- I think this is the organic one
because the taste is much stronger.
- I think this one.
- [Right] I think this one.
- Organic.
This is not.
- [Voiceover] And the
blue ones are organic.
- Ha-ho!
- Oh!
- Was I right?
You owe me a dollar.
(laughter)
- First impressions,
visually, these are bigger.
- Bigger, smaller.
- Must be--
- [Left] Probably not organic.
- Right.
- Probably organic.
- But do they think we're
going to think that.
- Right, they think that we think
that this one is organic,
so that means that actually
this one's organic.
- I eat apples 'cause I'm supposed to,
but they're not my fruit of choice.
- I always assumed organic
apples were smaller.
- Cheers.
- Mm. Mm-hmm.
- This looks gross.
I feel like it's been out in the sun.
- No, it doesn't.
- It looks bad, it's been cut poorly.
- I'd probably take one
bite and put it back,
like, at the refrigerator
in the morning time,
right before you brush your teeth, or pee.
- The texture is like
all, is like more powdery.
- I could see myself
eating this at the library.
'Cause I'm bored to death.
- Mmm.
- [Right] That's good.
- Love a good apple.
- Organic, inorganic.
- [Voiceover] It's the white one.
- Oh!
- [Man] Yeah!
- [Right] Oh, yo.
- I'm always wrong!
- Yeah!
- [Right] Yay!
We did it.
- The moral of the story is that
the organic fruits taste the worst.
- Yeah!
Oh man.
- How unfortunate.
(upbeat music)